una nueva jornada de la cop 27 marcada
por la participación de Estados Unidos
el presidente Joe biden defendió las
medidas adoptadas por su administración
dirigidas Al cuidado del medio ambiente
y los objetivos de reducción de
emisiones de gases contaminantes
hoy finalmente gracias a las acciones
que hemos tomado puedo pararme aquí como
presidente de Estados Unidos de América
y decir con confianza que Estados Unidos
alcanzará El objetivo de emisiones para
el año 2030
estamos demostrando que una buena
política climática es una buena política
económica es una base sólida para un
crecimiento económico duradero
resiliente e inclusivo está impulsando
El Progreso en el sector privado está
impulsando El Progreso en todo el mundo
durante su intervención algunos
presentes mostraron su desacuerdo con el
jefe de estado alzando una pancarta en
la que se leía personas versus
combustibles fósiles
a pesar de los logros exhibidos el
inquilino de la Casa Blanca no hizo
promesas concretas para financiar un
fondo contra los daños y las pérdidas
causados por el cambio climático por un
lado la administración puede atribuirse
el mérito de la ley de la reducción de
la inflación que es una ley realmente
importante que aprobó el congreso
pero en el escenario global de Estados
Unidos tiene otras obligaciones
importantes una proporcionar
financiamiento climático para la
transición a energía Limpia para los
países de bajos y medianos recursos
y la otra parte porque Estados Unidos es
el país más rico y ha contribuido tanto
en las emisiones que debe ayudar a
establecer un mecanismo de financiación
para pérdidas y daños
la participación en el contexto de las
elecciones de medio término de su país
que puede decidir el futuro de las
acciones climáticas de su gobierno en
sus dos últimos años de mandato